we're going to leave you now with Carrie  Underwood who paid a touching tribute to  Vince Gill honoring his remarkable  achievements over the years during the  CMT Giants Vince Gill television special  yeah the Sarasota special also feature  fellow country artists like Chris  Stapleton Keith Urban Luke Combs Reba  and Mary Morris but it was Carrie  Underwood who left Vince feeling  emotional as she performed a beautiful  rendition of Go Rest High On That  Mountain oh all right it was great  seeing all of you and you and we'll see  you next time bye everyone  instead  [Applause]  [Music]  it goes  [Applause]  and  [Music]  the Sun  [Applause]